The tides are turning, my friends. It's
2025 and the tides are turning. I've
been having discussions with my Muslim
friends for decades. If you've been
having discussions with your Muslim
friends, I'm sure one of the most
frustrating things you've experienced
over and over and over again is the
constant lying of the Dawagandists.
People like Ali Dawa, Muhammad Hijab,
Shikman, Ibn Farukq, Daniel Hikachu,
Eddie from the Dean Show, and so on.
simply make things up and they've been
exposed for it repeatedly. The
frustrating part, however, is that when
you prove conclusively that a Dagandist
has lied, your voice will be instantly
drowned out by thousands of his fans.
So, you correctly point out that someone
has lied, but all of a sudden thousands
of people are calling you the liar. And
you start to wonder, is this really
worth it trying to help here? And they
just don't want to listen. Am I wasting
my time? And the answer is no. You're
not wasting your time because some
people, even if they're the minority,
are listening and they'll see that
you're right. And once enough people see
that you're right, the tide starts
turning. Let's look at a perfect example
from yesterday. Eddie from the Dean Show
posted, "Did you know that Prophet
Muhammad is mentioned by name in the
Bible?" Really? By name where? In the
Hebrew text of Song of Solomon 5:16, the
word Mahmadim appears, sharing the same
root as Muhammad. Yet instead of keeping
it as a name, they translated it. You
don't translate a name. This was done to
deceive people and hide the truth. Why
alter it? Here's the proof. And the
proof is a video he posted 5 years ago.
You can watch it if you want to feel
yourself getting
dumber. So Muhammad is mentioned by name
in Song of Solomon 5:16, but evil
translators translate the name as
desirable or lovely in order to deceive
people and to keep them from realizing
that Muhammad is mentioned by name in
the verse. Let's read Song of Solomon
5:16 before we see what happened to poor
Eddie after he posted this nonsense. In
Song of Solomon 5, Solomon's wife is
looking for Solomon. And the daughters
of Jerusalem ask her what makes her
beloved Solomon so special. They say in
verse 9, "What is your beloved more than
another beloved, oh most beautiful among
women? What is your beloved more than
another beloved that you thus adure us?"
She responds by describing how
attractive he is. And after describing
his entire body, she declares, "His
mouth is most sweet, and he is
altogether desirable. This is my
beloved, and this is my friend, oh
daughters of
Jerusalem." Again, who is she responding
to? The daughters of Jerusalem, who
asked her why she's looking for Solomon
and why he's so special. Eddie from the
Dean Show claims that desirable here is
the name Muhammad and that evil
translators cover this up by translating
it desirable or
lovely. The obsession with finding
Muhammad in verses like this is
borderline insane. But if you tried to
refute this argument just 5 years ago,
your voice would be drowned out by a
mob. But times are changing, my friends.
Watch what happens when someone like
Eddie brings this up. Now, as of this
recording, his post has 460 likes. My
response has 2500 likes. Inspiring
Philosophy's response has a,000 likes.
And you can't say this is because we
just have more followers or something
because Eddie has way, way more
followers on X than we do. Eddie has
more than a million followers on X. By
comparison, I have around 92,000 and
Inspiring Philosophy has around
52,000. So Eddie's fans should be able
to drown us out
instantly. But they didn't at all
because the Da lies are becoming too
difficult to defend. Let's see why.
Inspiring Philosophy replied, "This is
utter nonsense. And if you haven't
learned this yet, you're either
incredibly uninformed or dishonest. It
makes no grammatical sense to say
Muhammad is mentioned by name in Song of
Solomon 5:16. And here's the video he
shared. Over the past several months,
I've been tagged in a number of videos
of Muslims claiming that Song of Solomon
5:16 predicts the coming of Muhammad.
But this is utter nonsense. First off,
the word in question is Makmad, which
means lovely or desirable. And in this
verse, it's in the plural form. So if
it's a name, it would actually be saying
there are multiple Muhammads. Now the
Muslim response is that it's made plural
out of respect. But there's no evidence
names in biblical Hebrew are made plural
out of respect. There's no Yahwa, David,
or Solomon. Some will bring up the
Hebrew word Elohim, which is in plural
form, but it's not a plural of respect.
It's a concretized abstract plural,
which means it could be used for a
single deity or many. It's like our
English word for sheep. You can refer to
one sheep or many sheep. Makmadim is not
a concretized abstract plural, nor is it
a plural of respect, nor was it ever
interpreted to be a name prior to the
rise of Islam. Also, the word right
before makmadim in this verse means each
or every or all. It's not what you would
use if you wanted to say he is Muhammad.
You can see the exact same word
construction in Numbers 23:13 where the
word means them all. So if you were
going to translate Song of Solomon 5:16
as literally as possible and it actually
meant Muhammad, you would say his mouth,
his sweets plural, each of him or all of
him is Muhammad's. That doesn't make
grammatical sense, which is why every
single Hebrew Bible scholar translates
this as lovely or desirable. If the
author was trying to say he is Muhammad,
you would find a similar construction to
what you see in Psalm 105:7 where it
says he is the Lord and it uses the
divine name. The fact that it means
lovely in the plural form makes more
sense with the Hebrew context. The bride
is describing her lover who throughout
the book is Solomon to the daughters of
Jerusalem and she describes various
aspects she finds attractive. His head
is the finest gold. His eyes are like
doves. His cheeks are like a bed of
spices. His lips are liies. His arms are
rods of gold. His legs are alabaster
columns. His mouth is most sweet. And
then we get to the climax where she
says, "All of him or every aspect of him
is desirable." Plural in Hebrew. As you
can see, she just got done describing
various aspects of Solomon that are
attractive. So, it makes sense in the
conclusion. She just says, "All of him
is lovely or desirable." This makes far
more sense than saying she breaks from
this to predict the coming of Muhammad
in a grammatically incorrect statement.
Moreover, the word Makm shows up at
other places in the Hebrew Bible where
it just means lovely or desirable. Why
would the word be a proper name in Song
of Solomon 5 if it's not understood that
way in other verses? This sounds like
special pleading. There is not a Hebrew
scholar alive that thinks Song of
Solomon 5:16 is predicting the coming of
Muhammad. And as you can see, it's
because there's a multitude of problems
with that interpretation. And before I
made this video, I checked all this over
with experts that are fluent in Hebrew.
If you don't agree, learn Hebrew and
take it up with the experts. Care to
debate inspiring philosophy on this,
Eddie? Of course you wouldn't. You
wouldn't dare. Da is deception. And you
know it. Prove me wrong. You won't. I
know it. You know it. And now your fans
slowly but surely are catching on. They
see you thumping your chest and claiming
you've got the proof, but they also see
you instantly backing down whenever
you're challenged. Classic da fail. Then
I responded to Eddie. I said, Eddie just
claimed that Mahmad in the Bible is
Muhammad. Interestingly, Ezekiel's wife
is also called Mahmad in Ezekiel 24:16.
Hence, according to Eddie, Muhammad was
Ezekiel's wife. Welcome to
Da. In Ezekiel 24, God tells the prophet
Ezekiel that his wife is about to die.
He says he's going to take away the
delight of Ezekiel's eyes, his wife.
Delight here in Hebrew is Mahmad. The
word Eddie says is actually a name that
shouldn't be translated. If Eddie is
correct, this would mean that Muhammad
was Ezekiel's
wife. Silly, right? Welcome to
Da. There are all kinds of problems we
can point out with this argument. We've
pointed out many times before that the
Daagandists are committing what we call
the phonic fallacy or the phonetic
fallacy, which is claiming that since
two words sound similar in two different
languages, they must mean the same
thing. And we give examples of the
absurdities that this can give rise to.
For instance, we point out that the
Hebrew word for mouse is akbar. Akbar in
Hebrew means mouse. If we want to commit
the phonic fallacy, we would conclude
that when Muslims say Allah Akbar,
they're actually saying Allah is a
mouse. Muslims, do you agree with this
approach to language? I don't. If you
really want to expose the argument, just
read The Song of Solomon. This is about
a romantic physical relationship between
Solomon and his bride. And a lot of the
book is them praising each other's
bodies. And it's all taking place in
Jerusalem, Jerusalem, Jerusalem,
Jerusalem,
Jerusalem. Speaking of Jerusalem, we've
partnered with Artzabox, a company that
gathers items from artisans in
Jerusalem. and Nazareth and Bethlehem
and other locations and ships them to
you in a box. There's a new one every
four months. It's like Christmas four
times a year. You get dishes,
decorations, pendants, candy, various
food items, and Israeli spices along
with a booklet that tells you about the
artisans and farmers who provide them.
The booklet also comes with a Hebrew
tutorial to get you started on learning
Hebrew. If you keep learning, you'll be
able to show people what a book like
Song of Solomon says in Hebrew. Arts of
Boxes are fun to open with your family
and they make great gifts. In fact, if
you want a pro tip, you can get a
quarterly Artza box and give out the
individual items as gifts. How cool will
you be in your church giving people
presents straight from Israel? So, sign
up to get your first Artza box. The link
is in the description box. Use the promo
code dizzle to get a discount and to let
them know who sent you. Back to the
tides turning in 2025. A lot of our
Muslim friends are realizing that the
claims of the Da guys simply can't be
defended and so they're not rushing to
defend them anymore. I showed how Eddie,
a guy who has more than a million
followers on X, got completely ratioed
by me and Inspiring Philosophy, even
though we have a fraction of his
followers. And if you'd like to really
have some fun, go to Eddie's post and
read through the other responses. He's
getting absolutely crushed because there
are simply too many people who know how
to expose the lies.
Now, over the past few decades,
Dawagandists have relied on their
followers to silence their critics. But
there would only be one or two critics.
So, it was easy for the mob to silence
the critic. Now, however, dozens of
critics show up to respond when a da guy
lies. It's a new world.
The darkness of Da is ending. A light
has dawned. And all we have to do to
accelerate the avalanche is to be
relentless. Now go be relentless.
[Music]